aussi large que la 205 mais plus courte
de 14 cm voici la toute dernière peugeot
la 106
une petite berline à essence 3 portes
moins de 14 centimètres cubes décliné
pour l'instant en huit versions ici la x
et si le plus puissant des modèles
testés pour vous sur les routes souvent
rude de l'aude et de l'ariège
100 chevaux 860 kg laïque celle-ci a du
tempérament les elle n'a ni les
accélérations ni le brio des premières
205 gti
la 106 a néanmoins hérité de son
excellente tenue de route et d'une
suspension très ferme
[Musique]
l'agrément de conduite a été améliorée
visibilité optimale freins à disque à
l'avant sur toute la gamme disques
ventilés pour la x6
la boîte de vitesses gagnerait à plus de
précisions en revanche l'insonorisation
est particulièrement réussi
[Musique]
190 km heure vitesse de pointe la x6 est
vivace bepa gloutonne 5 à 8 litres aux
cent selon la conduite
plus compacte que la 205 la 106 reste
habitable
le coffre n'a même pas été sacrifiées
l'ouverture des portes n'est pas très
commode mais à l'intérieur on trouve des
aménagements judicieux sièges arrière
rabattables partiellement en série sur
le haut de gamme
les équipements sont mieux disposés en
général plus accessible mais la plupart
sont en option
on appréciera néanmoins les miroirs de
courtoisie protéger de la poussière une
gentille attention aussi pour les
conductrices
en options vitres aux rétroviseurs
électriques chauffants de surcroît 10
700 francs pour l'équipement d'ensemble
ça n'est pas du luxe quand on doit se
partager la voiture
le moteur lui aussi est plus accessible
le capot reste ouvert à 90° dernière
subtilité la clé de contact commande à
distance la fermeture des portes
de 51 85 mille francs la nouvelle
peugeot se positionne d'emblée sur le
marché des berlines économique et
compact c'est le créneau le plus porteur
en europe peugeot cible une clientèle
nouvelle étrangère à la marque une
clientèle versatile qui aurait peut-être
aimé trouver là un peu plus de fantaisie
un peu plus d'audace
[Musique]